[музика]
так це найбільше якраз і знайшло
якщо озирнутися на всі боки взагалі-то
оглядається це сервіс це гора
навіть не пам'ятаю як вона називається у
кримських татар є імена кожному
ось кожній вершині кожному приладку
щитами такого 72 найменуванню все як я
адже і не пам'ятаю ну цей самий і зірок
вона виглядає з того будинку
належав нашого родового будинку
сервісі звідки розкуркулювали відправляли
ура у моїх батьків вони від туди
благополучно бігли
повертатися в крим одразу не стали
приїхали на мелітополь
а потім перебралися все-таки в крим але
рідне село не стали повертатися тому
що могли повідомити або квд
вони оселилися райдерів ска в районі це
північний крим
всього чоловічий я там народився
сорок четвертому році депортували у нас
з криму ось саме сила чоловіча
це на мою ось ту лікувати яка була
зруйнована потім силами наших
співвітчизників зупинено світові їх
можливості і ми звідси з Києва
надайте рибалці це допомоги відновленню
ти мечеті
коли я була тут а це було десь у
2010-му по-моєму було взагалі потворне
стані багато підлоги разово
вона була а зараз дещо відновлена
Висі раз я сидів тільки вже точніше під
вісімдесят дев'ятого року це буде моє
повернення в крим, а потім щорічно
як і в усіх селах крима кримські
татари вибудовували в один день на рік
день рідного села
я майже щороку приїжджав
це село зустрічалася з родичами та
зрозуміло відвідував будинок своїх батьків
це це схоже це мій
крихти будинок давно дуже давно знаходилася
у дому пройшовши такий непоказний але
ті часи в часи розкуркулювання
мабуть вважався, що він дуже такий
великий
всередині півтора це ж там за мірками
радянським сплячого це велика розкіш
розкручуємо відразу ж звичайно стала
питання у тому щоб викупити будинок хоча б
пам'ять про своїх батьків планували там
відреставрувати відремонтуйте зробити
якусь базу відпочинку для наших
співвітчизників але не вийшло
окупація 2000 14 роки фонд крим та все
майно його було заарештовано і зараз
вона подарує вам значиться а потім був
забороненими джейсами кримсько-татарського
адже народу зараз ось цей будинок такому
підвішеному стані
все наше село
така то щемлива туга та одразу
згадую ним і там господарниками
ходили цими ущелинами люди більше
літнього віку так дані
розповідали де хто жив що трапилося з
ними кого розстріляли хто кого
депортували і де він помер як
називається ці щілини ці гори, а ось так
[музика]
Ух ти